it's about money but of course
it's about a lot more than money
it's about workers and families their
jobs
their health and their well-being
i believe this agreement will be seen
as a pivotal moment in europe's
journey but it will also launch us
into the future in fact it's the first
time
the first time in european history that
our budget
will be clearly linked to our climate
objectives the first time the first time
that the respect for rule of law
is a decisive criteria for budget
spending
and the first time the first time
that you are jointly reinforcing
our economies against a crisis
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
exceptional
is
fundament foreign
i want to emphasize two more points
we have now the new own resources
tightly
linked to the repayment this is a big
step forward with a clear timetable
member states will benefit as they will
contribute less to repay
the investments and the new owned
resources will strengthen the european
union
also in the long term i'm glad that we
managed to safeguard this achievement
during the whole negotiations
and europe's recovery will be green
the new budget will power the european
green deal
it will accelerate the digitalization of
europe's economy
thanks to next generation eu national
reforms will be
boosted we invest in europe's future
and finally unlike
in previous crisis this time
member states have not opted
for an intergovernmental agreement but
they have entrusted the european
commission
of europe's recovery we will together
manage a total of
1.8 trillion euro
the bulk of the money will be channeled
through the programs in which the
european parliament is involved
next generation eu comes with a great
responsibility
and we are determined to bring about
reforms
and investment in europe nevertheless i
must also mention a difficult point
in their search for compromise leaders
have made
far-reaching adjustments into the new
mff and next generation you for example
in health migration external action
invest eu
they have not taken up the solvency
instrument
this is regrettable it decreases the
innovative part of the budget
even if more than 50 percent of the
overall budget mff and next generation
eu
will support modern policies
and so finally to conclude europe as a
whole
has now a big chance to come out
stronger from the crisis
today we've taken a historic step we can
be all proud of but another
important step remains ahead of us first
and foremost
we now have to work with the european
parliament to secure
agreement we have a lot of work ahead of
us
but tonight is a big step forward
towards recovery thank you
thank you madam president we'll be
taking a couple of questions
and first on is david
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
transformations
foreign
so um to the questions um the text
that has been agreed on the rule of law
has improved
it's a very clear in the document a very
clear commitment to the rule of law
and a very clear commitment to the
protection of the financial
interests of the union and
this is linked against this background
to the fact that the commission has
proposed an instrument
under which in case of breaches measures
will be adopted
so there's a very clear link a reference
the adopting or the voting will be by
qualified majority voting
and finally we will also introduce
instruments
to strengthen the controls of the eu
funds so there is more clarity there is
uh more distinction in the text and the
very clear reference
which was important not only to the rule
of law but also to the protection of the
financial interests
of the union and what the overall
package
is concerned and your question on
the priorities for the european union
it has it is an unprecedented size and
scope
of package that we have
1.8 trillion and
the importance here is that the whole
next generation generation eu package
of 750 billion is composed in a way
that the national recovery plans will be
aligned
with the european priorities that is the
european green deal that is the
digitization
that is resilience transmitted through
the country specific recommendations
so we have a very strong tool now
that we can work together with the
member states
on not only the recovery but at the same
time
through the investment leap forward
into a more sustainable a greener and
more digitized
future we want to build with a modern
single market so this is a unique
opportunity to modernize the european
union
thank you next question is for david
hersenhorn
from politico thank you much brent
uh good morning presidents president
michelle i wonder if you could address
the concern that president fonderline
just raised uh calling it regrettable
that leaders had to cut some of the most
innovative parts
of the mff also that
you had to persist in the rebates which
some people
feel are sort of a budget gimmick in
getting agreement here and if there was
a moment in this for you
president michelle when throughout this
summit what was the key moment when you
had a deal and for president thunderline
a lot of this uh package obviously will
be in national
uh plans the grants was the
issue of disagreement to your mind how
do you envision
member states best using these grants in
concrete ways obviously it's not like
rebuilding from an earthquake
or from a war it's a different type of
recovery in a concrete way what do you
envision the best national recovery
plans might look like
thank you
there is a very strong political will
around the table of
the european council to to act
to act in order to deliver because
we we are convinced uh that uh climate
change
that innovation uh that the support for
the social
economy for example uh it's key uh to
develop
a very strong program and with
this decision the mff and the recovery
fund we have the tools we have the means
in order to tackle those important
challenges for for the future
it's also important to to observe that
this package
is huge if you compare if you compare to
the cypher
of the europe of the european gdp also
important not to forget
that the recovery strategy will also uh
be developed
at the national level it means that as
european union uh you you you
we send a very strong signal we are
solid we are robust and we are united
and more than ever
we need to be united and we need
to be strong in order to face this
huge crisis
so uh to your question reforming
concerning the part um
how i envisage to make sure that the
investment goes in the right direction
the program is the recovery and
resilience
facility is established in a way that is
very clear
first of all it's voluntary so
member states can choose to come forward
with a national recovery plan
but it has to be aligned with the
european semester and there are the
country-specific recommendations
and the country-specific recommendations
address
the weak weaknesses or deficiencies in
member states that should be
improved where things should be reformed
and they were always very interesting
but
did not always have the necessary
effect in the member states because it
was up to them to
implement them or not now this
instruments has a new punch
because the european semester is now
connected to an enormous amount of
grants
or potentially loans so there's way more
punch behind
the country-specific recommendations and
the necessity to respect
the principles of the european green
deal and of the digitization as i set
the priorities of the european union
we can make sure that this will be
implemented in a proper way because
there will be milestones where you
have a look whether the milestones have
been reached and then
the necessary investment the the
payments will be dispersed
so there's a very clear plan to
have the both two goals on the one hand
the recovery of the member state but on
the other hand
to make sure that it's at the same time
a modernization
of the member states
thank you next question is for sam
fleming from the financial times
yes good good morning bye can i follow
up on the question
on please on uh rebates
um the clearly the rebates were only
maintained from previous drafts um but
they were actually increased
uh were the frugal states in these
discussions effectively trading their
support for
higher grants in exchange for higher
rebates uh were you disappointed
that that was the outcome that you saw
given the commission has previously
been recommending that rebates be phased
out
and do you think rebates now these high
rebates are basically here to stay
thank you
we took a decision today
for the next mff and for the recovery
fund
and in the framework of this decision we
took also some decisions
related to the to the rebates uh if we
face
uh a big crisis i repeat again and i
think what's important is the fact that
we find uh the we find the the way
in order to to take a very strong uh
decision and
indeed the rebate it's not a surprise
uh when i expressed the idea a few weeks
ago that we we will need we would need
to tackle different building blocks i
express the idea
that the rebates would be part of the
global package of the global decision
you you know at the level of the open
council it's very difficult we need to
decide by unanimity
and that's why it's important to show
respect for each other that's why it's
important also
to be able at the same time to take
strong and courageous decisions
and that's what we did today and
i remember only a few hours ago maybe
and certainly the last days there was
this global impression that it would be
impossible mission but we did it and
it's very important we were able to to
to take the decision we are united
and we sent the message europe is strong
next question is for lily bayer
please lily um thank you
much question which is uh for both
presidents
um today it's not really the end of the
saga because of course you still need to
convince the european parliament
and national parliaments to sign off on
this deal so i was wondering if you
could both maybe talk a little bit
about how you plan to convince
legislators
to sign off especially because we're
already seeing some members of the
european parliament
raising concerns about certain elements
of your package
thank you
we we show we show respect for the
important role
of the european uh parliament
and as you know we had many
consultations
many contexts with the european
parliament the last weeks the last
the last month and and of course we will
have the occasion
uh to uh to to to maintain the the
discussions
with the members of the european
parliament and it's key
uh for the european uh democratic
process of course and at the same time
you are right
we need also uh to show respect for the
responsibility
of the national parliaments man today
there is a strong signal there is a
strong message why because
27 head of states and out of governments
they took the decision to act together
and they are responsible
before the their own national parliament
i know that probably because it's the
democratic process
it will be difficult it will mean that
we will need to to explain
what are the arguments what are the
reasons for our
decision we are transparent it's also
very essential for this democratic
process
and i'm really convinced that with
political will with potential courage
with a constant dialogue it will be
possible to implement
what we have decided today well indeed
from tomorrow
on um work will continue
uh the text of the document has been to
be
transformed into a legal text that then
will
immediately go to the parliament and we
will start working
with that legal text with the parliament
to find agreement there are two pieces
that of
utmost importance on one hand there is
the own resources decision
on which a an opinion of the european
parliament is necessary
in order then to have the ratification
in the national parliaments and on the
other side on the other hand
there is the work with the mff
that has to be approved by the
adopted by the european parliament
i have triggered already once the
article
324 that is
in this case the the presidency
the president of the european parliament
and the president of the commission
to work together in order to
work on a budgetary matter so i'm
i'm convinced that such meetings will be
necessary also
now after we've found the agreement in
the european council
so you can see by my words there's a lot
of work ahead of us
but it is for a very important purpose
it concerns not only the future of
europe but it's also badly needed
thank you i have a question from pierre
emanuel
and i'm going to ask the question
addressed to the president of the
european council in french
purdue uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you to both presidents this
concludes our press conference
and all necessary documents will be
provided on our website
thank you at this early hour
you